hello and welcome to this video playing
eyes wide shut from Denmark doesn't show
looks like it looks like Denmark know
why doesn't it say no usually if you
hover of it weird what's going on here
hey I it looks like Denmark yeah
somewhat delayed ok so what is eyes wide
shut up to hear the 92 line in the limo
and when I t3m there are a couple of
options here I can go to be five but it
can also play this somewhat
unconventional stuff look for an old
Indian set up and he shuts it down
interesting should sit down well why
this is probably a bit better him just
got more space if I take and play be
fired
and probably wait for Momiji and see
what he does probably just be should be
three now yeah why this is a bit a bit
better here she going a form no F for
lower that looks completely anti
positional i'll just see get a knight to
c6 quickly that would be something that
[Music]
makes a forward while if you get in 96
that's really possible okay really wow
he doesn't like it's dark squared bishop
will come to you five with hopefully
good effect the only thing a little bit
my my development is not good so there
might be something okay look c6 what's
the deal maybe books is 60 coming
I should have put the Rope back I do i
do it actually let's just put it back
it's okay
so can he see wants to go to c6 now why
I a 5 this is not a big deal anymore I
think I'm not sure clean edge for looks
kind of attractive but there's Rugare
form so I just put the night on the best
square pillow and go from them and I
biggest goes here ok so now I can play
the movie as you can for Bishop h6 looks
pretty ok
ok
so what can I do here I Bishop f4
doesn't threaten all that much is the
thing penis the rukon is on c7 is
annoying
[Music]
hmm now then it didn't go all that well
when I didn't understand any of his move
but probably just because I absolutely
lucky i mean not because they were bad
but just because i didn't understand
them play for come back on let's play
for a trick here shall i play for trick
I let's check or check if he takes a
teenage to come in can the good work I
wait why do I know I can I take it
highline looks tempting them to take it
okay or do have a better square probably
not I rook takes you can play can take
with the hook Bishop takes Bishop before
I can take g3 intense and so on but you
can take with the friggin rope not so
good
an idea was to take and Bishop t4 is
also just to draw on sorry change my
cheeks I just pour some more put some
more wood on the on the fire or whatever
just make it as real as possible
[Music]
25 seconds you should see 5 i'm after
that ya know i can just take off course
yeah I am how lucky can you be able
physically preemie oh my god yeah
neither five yay what again
what the bloody game
they will take I guess huh yeah I cannot
do much him Jess Jess Jess oh man just
hit everything yeah freaking what ok I
just take a look see one I mean I have
who plays 94 okay twins or whatever I
Christ Jen place 94 yeah he did I was
just thinking king of one only move and
then I dropped lucozade ok this is what
I would have played and then just check
and play III isn't that way yeah
something like that should win what is
free i cannot do ma I'm just winning
materially also who can three pawns yeah
now what a stupid game yeah losing this
is kind of terrible especially after
have to move like this you really
shouldn't do the game with looks like
this by the opponent clearly just gives
me total control of the dark squares and
I mean Jen and it was too tempting
really not to take okay and that's
before yeah I mean this is ok I mean I'm
winning here it's just what it is if he
takes that rookie I was thinking would
be to maybe even
Lucas is 70 rook c7 no sorry I wanted to
take here actually why doesn't that work
takes checks yeah I so this isn't
actually great Wow I also check I was
thinking okay through you okay now can
it of the total mess but with a mess
where where I'm winning so yeah yeah
look at Vader's of course totally
ridiculous and tml a show just for me
just recap sure I was trying for who
gave to add in there anytime of course
yeah and he is between age three months
now now he's winning couldn't do Quinn
too much anymore with no time and it was
extremely silly extremely silly not yeah
anyway thanks for watching guys